This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保障真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以防万一》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方往往并不安全，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做，请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
收听《以防万一》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会迎来一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的自己。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是 TWO%。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗手约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝》（Trust Me, Babe）。在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个大时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemisbeke and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Today, we're going to talk about ADHD. Getting diagnosed with ADHD as an adult can feel like both a revelation and a bit of a reckoning. It's this moment when everything about how you've moved through the world probably make
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。大家好。我是杰米·斯贝克（Jemisbeke），欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析二十多岁的心理学。今天要聊的是注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）。成年后被诊断出患有 ADHD，既可能感觉像是一种启示，也可能像是一种清算。这是这样一个时刻：你过去在世界上生活的方式可能
a lot more sense, but you also now have to learn all these new ways to manage. That is exactly the experience of today's guest, Chris Wang. She's the founder of Shimmer. It's an ADHD coaching platform that has helped thousands of adults better understand their brains. And she herself was diagnosed in her 20s after years of feeling like she was kind of doing life wrong. And the thing is, her story is actually not a unique one. I've heard from so many of you who have had the same experience, been through the same process. So today, I wanted to talk to her about practical strategies for managing your time, energy, focus, managing ADHD in your 20s, especially when traditional productivity advice maybe hasn't ever worked for you. I also want to explore love and
突然变得很好理解，但同时你现在又必须学习所有这些新的管理方法。这正是今天的嘉宾克里斯·王（Chris Wang）的亲身经历。她是 Shimmer 的创始人。这是一个 ADHD 教练平台，已经帮助数千名成年人更好地了解他们的大脑。她自己也是在二十多岁时被诊断出来的，此前多年她一直觉得自己把生活过得一团糟。关键是，她的故事其实并不独特。我听到了很多人的反馈，他们都有过相同的经历，经历过相同的过程。所以今天，我想和她聊聊管理时间、精力、专注力，以及在二十多岁时管理 ADHD 的实用策略，特别是当传统的效率建议可能从来都不适合你时。我还想探讨与 ADHD 一相关的爱情和
dating with ADHD, why relationships can feel so intense. so confusing or addictive, how to handle romantic rejection, but also just rejection in general, and how to feel like you're not too much in a world that is asking everybody to be a lot smaller. I love this conversation. So without further ado, let's get into it. Chris Wang, welcome to the show. Thank you so much for coming on. Thank you so much for having me.
约会，为什么关系会让人觉得如此强烈、困惑或上瘾，如何处理浪漫拒绝，以及一般的拒绝，以及在要求每个人都变得更渺小的世界里，如何觉得自己并不是“太多了”（not too much）。我很喜欢这次对话。那么废话不多说，让我们进入正题。克里斯·王，欢迎来到节目。非常感谢你来参加。非常感谢邀请我。
You're an absolute icon. I'm sick. Oh, my gosh. I'm so excited. Can you tell the listeners a little bit about yourself and what you're. do. I feel like I gave a little introduction before, but I'm like, you can say it in your own words, in the better words, probably. I don't know if it's better, but I'm Chris. I'm the co-founder and CEO of Shimmer. I am also a late-diagnosed ADHDer, so I was diagnosed with ADHD when I was
你绝对是个偶像。我生病了。哦，天哪。我太兴奋了。你能向听众简单介绍一下你自己和你的工作吗？我觉得我之前做了一个简短的介绍，但我想，你可以用你自己的话，也许是更好的话来表达。我不知道是不是更好，我是克里斯。我是 Shimmer 的联合创始人兼首席执行官。我本身也是一个迟确诊的 ADHD 患者，我在
28, which I didn't know we'll get into that a little bit, but it's been a whirlwind of a journey navigating that diagnosis while creating Shimmer, which is a behavioral support platform, and As of date, we've done 75,000 coaching sessions, which is really exciting. Just thinking about how many people with ADHD have been a part of our journey, and many of them are late diagnosed as well. And the last piece is along the journey. This is very ADHD as well. Usually things kind of unfold.
28岁时被诊断出患有 ADHD，我不知道——我们待会儿会详细聊这个，但带着这个诊断，同时创建 Shimmer（一个行为支持平台）这一路走来，简直像是一场旋风，截至目前，我们已经完成了 75,000 次教练辅导，这真的让人很兴奋。只要想到有多少患有 ADHD 的人参与了我们的旅程，其中许多人也是迟确诊的。最后一部分是，在这一过程中——这也非常符合 ADHD 的特质，事情通常是自然展开的。
I have became an ADHD creator as well. So I started off by posting just my first series was ADHD Girl Hacks. So posting hacks that I've gleaned through my coaching journey and also those of the thousands of other folks who have gone through our platform. But since then have done ADHD goals, ADHD goals, and ADHD goals feels. So I know we'll get into tips and things like that afterwards. But it's been a little bit of a journey since that diagnosis. I'm really excited to hear about ADHD go dates. That's like something I'm particularly interested in hearing.
我也成了一个 ADHD 创作者。所以一开始我只是发帖，我的第一个系列是《ADHD 女孩秘籍》（ADHD Girl Hacks）。分享我通过自己的教练之旅，以及通过我们平台成千上万的其他用户收集到的秘籍。但从那以后，我又做了《ADHD 目标》（ADHD Goals）、《ADHD 目标》以及《ADHD 感受》（ADHD Goals Feels）。所以我知道我们待会儿会聊到一些建议和类似的话题。但自从那个诊断以来，这段旅程可以说是经历了一番波折。我真的很期待听到关于 ADHD 约会日（ADHD go dates）的事情。这正是我特别想听的一个话题。
but this definitely won't surprise you. It did surprise me. How many people reach out to me with a similar story of like I had all of these difficulties, or actually like sometimes even a lack of difficulties when I was at school. And then suddenly I became an adult and, you know, all the things that people had ignored or that I like worked really hard to mask, like kind of came to the surface. And here I was at 27, 28, 29, like basically.
但这绝对不会让你感到意外。这确实让我感到意外。有多少人联系我，诉说相似的经历，比如“我在学校时有所有这些困难”，或者“其实有时候甚至没什么困难”。然后突然间我成年了，你知道的，所有人以前忽视的那些事情，或者我努力掩饰的那些事情，开始浮出水面。然后我就这样到了 27、28、29 岁，基本上是在
discovering a new aspect of my identity and of how I operate, can you tell us a little bit about your story and maybe like what it felt like or how it was growing up? Did you feel different? And when you maybe realized that like there was a label for this or a series of symptoms that could kind of explain it. Yeah. So I will first preface by saying that people's ADHD looks really different. And I'm glad you're asking for individual stories because I think sometimes it's very easy. to hear a story and not hear yourself in it or hear a story and do hear yourself in it and feel like you either don't have ADHD or have ADHD. So I think it's really important to learn about the symptoms, learn about the different ways the symptoms can coexist with each other and also go through that process yourself. And I also will want to say if your listeners haven't really dug into ADHD, there's also three types of ADHD.
探索我身份的新方面以及我的运作方式。你能跟我们讲讲你的故事吗？比如成长是什么感觉？你觉得自己不同吗？以及你是什么时候意识到这有一个标签，或者有一系列可以解释它的症状的？好的。首先我要说明的是，每个人的 ADHD 表现真的很不一样。我很高兴你询问个人的故事，因为我觉得有时人们很容易听到一个故事却在其中找不到自己，或者听到一个故事对号入座，从而觉得自己要么有 ADHD，要么没有 ADHD。所以我认为了解这些症状、了解这些症状如何共存，以及自己经历这个过程是非常重要的。我也想说，如果你的听众还没有深入了解过 ADHD，其实 ADHD 也有三种类型。
And I'll share which one I am as well. But there's the hyperactive impulsive ADHD, which are folks who, as a kid, we're kind of bouncing off of walls, super talkative, probably getting into trouble. And as adults generally won't look as disruptive, but maybe it's chatty, maybe it's more internally being more hyperactive. And so that's kind of on the hyperactive impulsive side. And then there's the inattentive side, which is the other type that generally a lot of the times women will have and girls will have, which a lot of the times when you're younger will be internally presenting as also those are the daydreamers, the ones who maybe as an adult struggle to follow conversations
我也会分享我是哪一种。有一种是多动冲动型 ADHD，这类人小时候精力极其旺盛，像停不下来一样，超级健谈，可能经常惹麻烦。作为成年人，通常看起来没有那么具有破坏性，但也许很健谈，或者内在表现得更多动。所以这是多动冲动这一类。然后是不注意型，这是女性和女孩通常会有的另一种类型。很多时候，当你年幼时，它会在内在表现为白日梦患者，可能是成年后难以跟上谈话，
or get lost in your own daydreams in your head. And so that inattentive ADHD will look really different from the hyperactive ADHDer. And the third type, which is the type that I am, fortunately or unfortunately, is the combined type. So that's when you have symptoms from both sides. And so when you meet someone who has ADHD, they could look really different if they just fall within those three buckets, but also if they have symptoms. have other sorts of intersectionalities and co-occurrences with other mental health conditions. So I just wanted to preface that.
或者在自己的白日梦里迷失。因此，这种不注意型 ADHD 的表现与多动型 ADHD 会非常不同。第三种类型，也就是我所属的类型，不幸还是万幸，是混合型。这就是你同时具备两方面的症状。所以当你遇到一个患有 ADHD 的人时，如果他们只是落在这三个类别中，他们的表现可能会非常不同，此外，如果他们还伴有其他交叉性特征，以及与其他心理健康状况的共病，情况就会更复杂。我只想先说明这一点。
And so for me, I have all the most of the symptoms, but specifically the ones that were the most alien when I was a kid was definitely on the hyperactive side. I was super talkative. I was constantly distracting people around me. I was always being told I was too loud or just to sit down or be quiet, just constantly in the way. I think as I grew up, I've been thinking about this a lot. I think I've heard a lot of stories of folks who their self-confidence and anxiety just really increases over time, especially as girls.
对我来说，我有大部分症状，但特别是在我小时候显得格格不入的，绝对是多动这一侧。我超级健谈。我不断地分散周围人的注意力。我总是被告知我太吵了，或者让我坐下、安静点，总是在碍事。随着年龄的增长，我一直在思考这个问题。我听过很多关于人们的自信心和焦虑感如何随着时间推移而真正增加的故事，尤其是女孩子。
And so there's actually this stat that people with ADHD hear 20,000 more negative messages by the time that they're 10 years old in comparison to their non- ADHD peers, which is pretty significant. And you can imagine, especially if you don't have the right support system or other ways that you have. feel confidence that that would yield just a lower self-perception, lower goals, and just the way that you move through life is going to be really different. And so getting support and getting at least awareness and acknowledgement that you are different and you will navigate things differently as a kid, I think is super, super important. I was lucky in that a mix of, I think, being Asian and having a really strong emphasis for my parents on grades and being smart. I did get good grades and that helped me build a sense of confidence when I was younger.
实际上有一个统计数据：患有 ADHD 的人在 10 岁时听到的负面信息比没有 ADHD 的同龄人多 20,000 条，这是一个相当显著的数字。你可以想象，特别是如果你没有正确的支持系统，或者没有其他方式来建立自信，这会导致较低的自我认知、较低的目标，并且你在这个世界上的生活方式也会大不相同。因此，获得支持，至少获得意识和认可——即作为一个孩子，你是不同的，你处理事情的方式也会不同——我认为这是超级、超级重要的。我很幸运，一方面是由于身为亚裔，父母对成绩和聪明有着非常强的重视。我确实取得了不错的成绩，这帮我在年幼时建立了一种自信心。
So even though I was getting kicked out of class all the time, I got suspended. The impact on me as a kid actually wasn't as strong. And you'll hear all sorts of different stories. I think for me, when we think about diagnosis, the impact didn't get really strong for me until I became an adult. And all of those kind of structures and goals kind of fell off. It was actually when I first started my business and I, one, we were in the pandemic. And so everything was online. And I was not able to get a lot of that visual and physical stimulation from other people. And then two, I was an entrepreneur and not only was I creating structures for myself, but I was expected to create structures for other people as well. And that for me was when everything started kind of crumbling. And it took me that long to actually realize that all of these symptoms were related to ADHD. And a big part of that also came from my cultural upbringing of not. talking about mental health than not talking about ADHD since I was a kid. And there's,
所以尽管我总是被赶出课堂，我还被停过学。作为孩子，这对我实际的影响其实并没有那么大。你会听到各种各样不同的故事。对我来说，当我们想到确诊时，它对我产生巨大影响其实直到我成年、所有这些结构和目标消失后才真正显现。事实上，正是在我刚开始创业的时候——当时我们在疫情期间。所以一切都是在线的。我无法从其他人那里获得大量的视觉和身体刺激。其次，我是一名创业者，我不但要为自己建立结构，还被期望为其他人建立结构。对我和我来说，那正是一切开始崩塌的时候。我花了那么长时间才真正意识到所有这些症状都与 ADHD 有关。这很大程度上也源于我的文化背景：从小就不谈论心理健康，不谈论 ADHD。这有一个，
I think it's called like the rule of seven where it's a marketing thing where a consumer needs to see like seven ads. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I feel like it's kind of similar with my ADHD. I had a friend told me tell me maybe I have ADHD because he has ADHD. I had Instagram. The for you page was getting at me. And so I really just started seeing it from here and there. So it was a very non-linear journey to finally thinking, oh, maybe it's this. And then once you, then you go down the rabbit hole or I went down the rabbit hole and started researching. And that's what led me to my diagnosis. So again, like as I said, I think everyone, I've heard so many stories by now. Like everyone's story looks so different. And depending on your
我想这叫“七次法则”（rule of seven），是个营销概念，意思是消费者需要看到七次广告。对，对，对。我觉得我的 ADHD 也差不多。有个朋友告诉我，说我可能患有 ADHD，因为他有 ADHD。我的 Instagram 动态“为你推荐”（for you page）也开始推送相关内容。因此我真的是从这里看到一点，那里看到一点。所以，最后认为“哦，也许就是这个”是一段非常非线性的旅程。一旦你有了这个想法，你就会陷入知识的深渊，或者说我陷入了知识的深渊并开始研究。这最终引领我找到了诊断。所以再次重申，就像我说的，每个人——我到现在已经听过太多故事了。每个人的故事都大不相同。这取决于你的
culture and your other intersectionalities and also just the cards that you were really dealt with and the support that you had throughout your life. It's so interesting, like going back to what you said about. the negative messaging that kids with ADHD will get, but also how some of them are actually highly functional in schooling environments. Like when you said that, you got such great grades. Like I'm thinking about my best friend who also got a diagnosis for ADHD. And I remember sitting with her and her mom doing the test.
文化、你的其他交叉身份特征，以及你手中拿到的牌，还有你在生活中得到的支持。这太有趣了，回到你刚才说的关于患有 ADHD 的孩子会收到负面信息，但也有一些人在学校环境中实际上功能高度良好。当你这么说的时候——你拿到了那么好的成绩——我想到了我最好的朋友，她也被诊断出患有 ADHD。我记得我和她以及她妈妈坐在一起做测试。
Do you know what I'm talking about? like the scaling thing. Like it's like maybe 20 pages long. Yep. And her mom being like, you really didn't struggle with that. You really didn't struggle with. No, that doesn't describe you at all.
你知道我在说什么吗？那个量表。可能像20页那么长。是的。她妈妈说：“你真的没有在这上面挣扎吗？你真的没有……”不，这根本不符合你的描述。
And Aaron being like, no, but I like, you saw the outside of that. This was the inside of that. And how hard it was. And also like, you know, her day was so organized. She had like 20 different activities per day. There was always something to like keep her preoccupied,
而爱伦（Aaron）则说：“不，但是我觉得——你看到的是外在表现。这是内心的感受。这有多难。”而且，你知道，她的生活太有条理了。她每天大概有20项不同的活动，总是有某件事来让她保持忙碌，
but also a structure within which, you know, it was so routine focused. My question around that is, do you see a lot of people be like, I cannot possibly have this disorder because I don't look a certain way or because, you know, I'm not just, I'm not in this description and all this idea of what this is? Yeah, 100%. I think one thing that is that woman hear a lot is that you're too smart to have ADHD. Yeah. And that happens as an adult, happens as a kid, and ADHD has nothing to do with intelligence. There are people who are, who are, have higher IQs with ADHD and lower. It doesn't, it's not
但这也是一种结构，你知道的，高度专注于常规。我围绕这个的问题是：你是否看到很多人会说：“我不可能有这个障碍，因为我看起来不像那样”或者“因为，你知道，我不只是，我不符合这个描述以及对它的所有想象？”是的，百分之百。我认为女性经常听到的一句话是：“你太聪明了，不可能有 ADHD。”是的。这在成年时会发生，在小时候也会发生，而且 ADHD 与智力毫无关系。有 ADHD 患者的智商更高，也有更低的。它并不
correlated. And also like with your friend, that's something I hear too as well. There's this one example I always give. If you ask someone with ADHD, how often do you lose your keys? They often say, I lose it multiple times a day. Or they say, I never lose my keys. And you say, okay, well, why? They say, because I have this very elaborate system and they'll have an entire. system as to why they don't lose their keys. So both those people have ADHD. It's just that they've dealt with that differently. So intelligence is one is definitely one. And another one is women who have presented with inattentive symptoms because they weren't in the way of their teacher or their parent. And they oftentimes have been told that they don't have ADHD because we haven't
相关。而且，就像你的朋友一样，这也是我经常听到的。我总是举这样一个例子。如果你问一个患有 ADHD 的人：“你多久弄丢一次钥匙？”他们通常会说：“我一天弄丢好几次。”或者他们会说：“我从不弄丢钥匙。”你问：“好吧，为什么？”他们会说：“因为我有一套非常精细的系统”，他们会有一整套系统来解释他们为什么不弄丢钥匙。所以这两个人都患有 ADHD。只是他们处理方式不同。因此，智力绝对是其中之一。另一个表现是患有不注意型症状的女性，因为她们没有妨碍到老师或家长。而且她们经常被告知自己没有 ADHD，因为直到最近，我们才真正理解这种诊断在女性和女孩身上的表现是什么样的。所以现在情况正在改变。现在很多作为父母的千禧一代了解了更多关于 ADHD 的知识，能够在自己的孩子身上看到这一点，并且能够与医生或老师为孩子发声，这在这一历程中非常有帮助。比如我们看到很多会员来到我们这里，要么是因为他们的孩子被确诊了，通常是千禧一代；要么是反过来，他们自己被确诊了，然后他们说：“我开始在我的孩子身上看到这些症状了，
really understood until recently what that diagnosis looks like in women, what it looks like in girls. And so that's changing now. And a lot of the times now with millennials as parents, knowing more about ADHD, being able to see this in their kid and then being able to advocate for their kid with their doctors or their teachers has been really helpful in this journey. Like we see a lot of members come to us either who were diagnosed because their kid was diagnosed and just generally millennials or people the other way around who they were diagnosed. And then they're like, I'm starting to see these symptoms in my kids. how do I best support them?
我该如何最好地支持他们？我如何确保他们不会经历我所经历的事情？”我认为这非常有趣，因为我确信你也见过。有各种各样的文章都在说“现在每个人都有 ADHD 啦，啦啦啦啦”。是的。其实在我说接下来的话之前，你对那种标题党或者那种文章或头条有什么看法？是的，我觉得这有点问题，但我理解它从何而来。当你听到人们在脱离语境的情况下说出他们的症状时，听起来像是：“哦，对啊，
How do I make sure that they don't go through the experience that I went through? And I think it's so interesting because I'm sure you've seen this. There's all these articles that's like everybody has ADHD now, blah, blah, blah, blah. Yeah. Actually, before I say what I'm going to say, what are your thoughts on those typecastle, or those kind of articles or headlines? Yeah, so I think it's a little bit problematic because, but I get where, comes from. When you hear people say their symptoms out of context, it sounds like, oh, yeah,
我该如何确保他们不会经历我所经历的痛苦呢？我觉得这很有趣，因为我确信你也见过这种情况。有各种各样的文章都在说现在每个人都有多动症（ADHD），巴拉巴拉之类的。是的。其实，在我说我想说的话之前，你对那种播客，或者那种文章或标题有什么看法？是的，所以我认为这有点问题，但我理解这背后的原因。当你听到人们脱离语境地讲述他们的症状时，听起来就像，哦，是的，
I lose my keys too, right? Like, I also stub my toe on the chair. I always, I also struggle to get organized. I struggle to focus. So these are all universal symptoms. And especially in the inattention economy today, people are feeling those more strongly. And so I think that there's a couple things here. Like one, people with ADHD face those symptoms way more severely. And every single day, all day. And imagine if you can imagine you feeling that once in a while, imagine if someone was feeling it all day and it just becomes like, let's say you have a plan to go to a meeting that day and then you end up spending your entire morning going back and forth for getting like 17 things. And like what that does to you when you arrive at that meeting and
我也经常弄丢钥匙，对吧？就像，我也经常把脚趾撞到椅子上。我总是，我也很难组织自己。我很难集中注意力。”所以这些都是普遍存在的症状。特别是在当今的注意力经济中，人们对此感触更深。所以我认为这里有几点。首先，患有 ADHD 的人面对这些症状要严重得多，而且是每天、整天都在面对。想象一下，如果你偶尔能感受到这种感觉，想象一下如果有人一整天都感到这种感觉，它就会变成——比方说，你今天计划去开个会，然后你最终把整个早上去回奔波，忘掉了17件事情。当你到达那场会议时，这种经历对你意味着什么？
you're not confident, you feel like you're dumb and then you botched the meeting. And so there's just so many effects that are just, they compound on each other. And so I think what people don't understand is the compounding effect of the severity and the frequency because the other thing about the ADHD diagnosis is that you have to have impairment in your life for you to actually get that diagnosis. So that's actually part of the diagnosis criteria and has to show up before you're 12. That's how the DSM-5 is currently structured. So that's one thing. And then the other thing, I think just from a human perspective, I feel like if you can resonate with people instead of saying everyone has ADHD, I would challenge people to think, okay, I can resonate with that feeling.
你没有自信，你觉得自己很笨，然后你把会议搞砸了。因此，会有如此多的负面影响，它们相互叠加。所以我认为人们不了解的是严重程度和频率的叠加效应，因为关于 ADHD 诊断的另一个事实是，你必须在生活中受到损害，才能真正获得诊断。这其实是诊断标准的一部分，而且必须在12岁之前显现。这就是目前的 DSM-5（《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》第五版）的结构。所以这是一点。第二点，我认为从人类的角度来看，我觉得如果你能与人们产生共鸣，而不是说“每个人都有 ADHD”，我会挑战人们去思考：“好吧，我能对那种感觉产生共鸣。”
And I imagine if they're feeling this all the time and way more intensely and it's impacting their life, instead of dismissing them through that resonance, it should, we should take more an approach of empathy of like, okay, well, I can understand a little bit. I can only imagine how hard this is for you. And so taking that, I think that mindset shift is something that a lot of folks, especially on the internet, I would challenge them to try to think of it in that way. I also just think like, anytime I see those articles, like that's just factually incorrect. Like not everybody has ADHD. Like, and I think it's one of those things where there's a specific kind of person who like makes everybody's health their business and like everybody's lives their business. And I think it's especially like an older generation who are like, I don't want to talk about this. Like everybody is the same. Why can't it just be like as it once was? And when they hear stories about ADHD and the media or in the news, it's like when you hear about playing crashes, right?
我想如果他们一直都在以更强烈的方式感受到这一点，并且它正在影响他们的生活，我们不应该通过这种共鸣去否定他们，而应该采取更多同理心的态度，比如：“好吧，我能理解一点。我只能想象这对你来说有多难。”因此，采取这种思维模式的转变是许多人——尤其是在互联网上的人——我希望挑战他们去以这种方式思考。我只是觉得，每当我看到那些文章，那在事实上就是不正确的。并非每个人都有 ADHD。而且我认为这是特定类型的人才会做的事情，他们把每个人的健康都当成自己的事，把每个人的生活都当成自己的事。我认为这尤其是老一辈人的想法，他们会说：“我不想谈这个。每个人都一样。为什么不能就像以前那样？”当他们在媒体或新闻中听到关于 ADHD 的故事时，这就像你听到飞机失事一样，对吧？
it makes you believe that they're a lot more common. It makes you believe that this is actually a problem. And they don't actually have all the full information. Like there's all these cognitive biases that are making it seem like a fake epidemic. And it must be like such a struggle as, you know, someone with ADHD yourself to be like, you don't know what I went through to get this diagnosis. It wasn't like I just went in and said, I think I have this. And okay, now give me the lateh.
这让你相信它们更常见。这让你相信这真的是个问题。而他们其实并没有获得全部信息。这里有各种各样的认知偏误，让它看起来像是一场虚假的流行病。作为你这样一个本身患有 ADHD 的人，这一定是一场巨大的挣扎，比如：“你根本不知道我为了得到这个诊断经历了什么。我不是随随便便走进来说，‘我觉得我有这个，好了，现在给我开药’。”
like can you talk a little bit more about how that diagnosis maybe actually helped you understand yourself better and maybe was actually like as you said a long time coming yeah so I think one of the biggest things for me and is for a lot of our members is that pre-diagnosis everything about you that you didn't know yet was related to ADHD you just attribute it to your personality or you attribute it to you as a human as like your core human. So for example, I used, I always just thought I was a bad kid. I was like, I'm a bad kid. I'm a bad influence. It makes sense that other my kids, my friends, parents don't want me to hang out with them. Like I didn't even question these things. They were just facts about me. And now having this diagnosis, being able to look back and say like,
你能多谈谈这个诊断实际上是如何帮助你更好地了解自己，并且可能真的像你所说的那样，经历了很长时间才到来吗？是的，我认为对我和我们的许多会员来说，最大的事情之一就是，在确诊之前，你身上所有你还不知道是与 ADHD 相关的事情，你都只会归咎于你的个性，或者你作为一个人的核心特质。例如，我过去一直觉得自己是个坏孩子。我会想：“我是个坏孩子。我是一个坏榜样。其他孩子、我朋友的父母不想让我和他们一起玩，这是合情合理的。”我甚至没有去质疑这些事情。它们只是关于我的事实。现在有了这个诊断，能够回过头来说：
okay, I wasn't a bad kid. Like these were the things that I was struggling with. This is why. And this is probably what I needed in the time to be able to be supported. But also going forward, so I like, I'm same with the coaching methodology. I'm very future oriented. I think it's important to understand the past and sometimes it helps untangle those things to rewrite your identity. But for me going forward, it's also about understanding what comes from my ADHD so I can better communicate around it and communicate with myself so that I don't feel like a bad person, but also communicate with the people around me to have the right language. So it doesn't sound like excuses or I'm just like, oh, I'm just always late. I can't do anything about it. So it's not
“好吧，我不是个坏孩子。这些是我当时在挣扎的事情。这就是原因。这可能是我当时为了获得支持所需要的东西。”但同时展望未来——就像我对待教练方法的态度一样，我是非常面向未来的。我认为理解过去很重要，有时它有助于解开那些事情以重塑你的身份。但对我来说，展望未来也是关于理解哪些来自我的 ADHD，这样我可以更好地围绕它进行沟通，并与自己沟通，这样我就不会觉得自己是个坏人，同时也能与周围的人沟通，使用正确的语言。这样听起来就不会像是在找借口，或者像是我在说：“哦，我总是迟到。我对此无能为力。”所以它不是
about that. It's more of like, okay, well, I just want you to know that because of my ADHD symptoms, it's hard for me to be on time. These are some things that I'm trying to do to mitigate that. These are some things that if it's not too much for you, maybe you can do this to help me with this process as well. And so it really gives you that language. And that makes it, especially in a partnership about like you, me, and then there's ADHD, right? Like, We're talking about how we can solve for this thing. And I'm taking responsibility for my part, but I'm also asking as a partner if you can be able to support me in that instead of just being like tied to an identity that you're not sure what is you and what is ADHD. So I think for me, that's been one of the biggest pieces.
关于那个的。更多的是：“好吧，我只是想让你知道，由于我的 ADHD 症状，我很难按时到达。以下是我正在尝试做的一些事情来缓解这种情况。如果对你来说不是太勉强的话，也许你可以做这些事情来帮助我度过这个过程。”它真的给了你这种语言。这使得它——特别是在伙伴关系中——变成了你、我和 ADHD 的关系，对吧？我们在讨论如何解决这个问题。我在为我自己的部分承担责任，但我也作为一个伴侣请求你是否能够在这方面支持我，而不是被束缚在一个你不确定什么是你、什么是 ADHD 的身份上。所以对我和我来说，这是最重要的事情之一。
And then I think the other piece is around just understanding what my strengths and weaknesses are with the lens of ADHD. not so I can fix all of the weaknesses but more so that I can put myself in situations where I'm leveraging my strengths more. And that's been the main part of the journey that I've been on with coaching and a lot of our members are on with coaching as well as really that reframe to place yourself
然后我认为另一部分是，通过 ADHD 的镜头来理解我的优势和劣势是什么。不是为了让我能修复所有的弱点，而是为了让我能把自己放在更多地发挥我优势的环境中。这成为了我和教练一起经历的主旅程的主要部分，我们的许多会员也正在与教练一起经历这段旅程，这确实是一种重新构架，以便把你放在
in better situations and communicate better rather than just thinking, oh, there's all these things that are bad about me that I need to fix. Well, this kind of brings me to this proactive approach to ADHD that you talk about. Speak me through this specific perspective. Because as I understand it, you know, we've gone back to the history of like
更好的环境中，并进行更好的沟通，而不是仅仅认为：“哦，我有这么多不好的地方，我需要修复它们。”嗯，这让我想到你谈到的对待 ADHD 的积极主动的方法。跟我讲讲这个具体的视角。因为据我所理解的，你知道，我们回到了历史，
what it would maybe have been like to be a kid who has a undiagnosed ADHD and you're called a nuisance and you're called annoying. And as you said, you know, parents don't want their kids to hang out with you. Like, you know, you're scolded all the time. Probably when you get an ADHD diagnosis, it would be very easy for you to think of it as a weakness.
作为一个未被诊断出 ADHD 的孩子会是什么样子：你被称为讨厌鬼，你被称为烦人。正如你所说，你知道，父母不希望他们的孩子跟你玩。就像，你总是被责骂。可能当你得到 ADHD 诊断时，你很容易把它看作是一种弱点。
you like to think of it as a strength. Talk me through that a little bit more. Yeah, I think it's a, it's such a fine balance and it's a really big sticking point in the ADHD community. I think on one end, there's the extremely deficit-driven approach of I have ADHD, I have all of these things that are wrong with me and I need to fix all of them. That is not the mental model I ascribe to, but also on the other end, there's this superpower model, which I think that, borders on toxic positivity when you say that ADHD as a whole is a superpower and a lot of ADHDers in the community have an allergic reaction to that with good reason because it undermines the support that is required for people with ADHD. If everyone just believes that we're all
而你却喜欢把它看作一种优势。再多跟我讲讲这一点。是的，我认为这是一种如此微妙的平衡，也是 ADHD 社区中一个非常棘手的问题。我认为一方面，有一种极度以缺陷为驱动的方法，即“我有 ADHD，我身上有所有这些毛病，我需要修复所有这些毛病”。这不是我所信奉的心智模型，但在另一方面，也存在着“超能力模型”（superpower model），我认为这
superheroes because we have ADHD, then we won't get the right support, the right accommodations that we need from when we're a child to when we're adult. So I paint the two extremes because there are a lot of people who sit on each end of that extreme, I think it's important to take a balanced approach, and it's the approach that we take at Shimmer as well, where you do have challenges as a person with ADHD, and those challenges are important to be aware of, but it doesn't mean you need to solve all of them. You don't need to sit there saying, I have bad memory. I need to solve that problem. I need to train my brain to have better memory because I'm never going to have great memory. That's just not going to happen for me, and that's okay. I accept that.
当你说 ADHD 整体上是一种超能力时，它近乎于有毒的积极性（toxic positivity），而社区中的许多 ADHD 患者对此有着过敏反应，这是有充分理由的，因为它削弱了 ADHD 患者所需的支持。如果每个人都仅仅因为我们有 ADHD 而相信我们都是超级英雄，那么我们就无法得到从童年到成年所需的正确支持和合理的便利设施。所以我画出了这两个极端，因为有很多人坐在每一个极端上，我认为采取平衡的方法很重要，这也是我们在 Shimmer 采取的方法，即作为一个患有 ADHD 的人，你确实面临挑战，意识到这些挑战很重要，但这并不意味着你需要解决所有这些挑战。你不需要坐在那里说：“我记性不好。我需要解决这个问题。我需要训练我的大脑拥有更好的记忆力”，因为我永远不会拥有极佳的记忆力。那是不可能的，没关系。我接受这一点。
instead it's contextual. So maybe I don't want to be in a job where I'm playing Jeopardy or whatever required. Yeah, exactly, right? And so there's other ways to approach it. But then on the other hand, people with ADHD and all people, not just people with ADHD, but people with ADHD don't often realize this, is that they have strengths. And there are strengths that are common for people with ADHD around creativity, around nonlinear thinking. Even impulsivity can be something that is positive, like for entrepreneurship. Sometimes you do need that impulsivity to be able to take risks that other people won't take. So every kind of weakness oftentimes has like a strength on the other side.
相反，它是情境化的。所以也许我不想从事一份需要玩《危险边缘》（Jeopardy）或其他要求的工作。是的，完全正确！所以有其他的方法来处理它。但另一方面，患有 ADHD 的人以及所有人——不仅是 ADHD 患者，但 ADHD 患者往往没有意识到这一点——他们拥有优势。对于患有 ADHD 的人来说，有一些常见的优势围绕着创造力、非线性思维。甚至冲动也可以是积极的，比如对于创业而言。有时你确实需要那种冲动，去冒别人不敢冒的风险。因此，每一种弱点往往都有其另一面的优势。
And so I think it's important to take a balanced view to who you are as a whole. And then on top of that, I think a big part of our approach and what one of the first things I realized needed to happen as an ADHDer is before even doing all of that, you really need to define where you want to go as a person. And people with ADHD have impaired perspective memory, which is basically looking into the future. We often just spin our wheels faster and faster in no particular direction, which, again, is probably relatable to a lot of people. And so the first thing we do in coaching is help people think about where they want to go in the future. And so for some people, that'll be a really hard activity because they've never thought of it.
所以我认为对作为一个整体的自己采取平衡的观点是很重要的。除此之外，我认为我们的方法的一个重要部分，也是我作为一个 ADHD 患者意识到需要发生的第一件事是，甚至在做所有这些之前，你真的需要明确作为一个人你想去哪里。患有 ADHD 的人受损的是前瞻记忆（prospective memory），这基本上就是展望未来。我们往往只是在没有特定方向的情况下，让我们的思维之轮越转越快，这再次可能引起许多人的共鸣。因此，我们在教练辅导中做的第一件事就是帮助人们思考他们未来想去哪里。对某些人来说，这将是一项非常困难的活动，因为他们从来没有想过这个问题。
And for some people, it'll be easier. So once you define that, then it becomes easier to say, do we really need to fix all the challenges that you have to get there? Or do we maybe need to like switch gears a little bit? Or are there certain strengths that you can be able to draw and to move you closer to that future that you envision? And so both of those two things in terms of looking into the future and then taking steps to get there that's more aligned with your strengths and challenges. Together creates an entire system that helps you just live a life that you're more calm, happy, fulfilled. feeling well, whatever you want to define as your kind of objective function. It just sounds like a very realistic approach.
对某些人来说会更容易。一旦你明确了这一点，那么说“我们真的需要解决你为了到达那里而面临的所有挑战吗？或者我们也许需要稍微换个档期？或者是否有某些你可以利用的优势来推动你更接近你所设想的未来？”就会变得容易得多。因此，这两件事结合起来——展望未来，然后采取更符合你的优势和挑战的步骤到达那里——共同创造了一个完整的系统，帮助你过上更平静、更快乐、更有成就感的生活，
Like there's no extremes in that of like either this is a superpower or like stomp out every single thing about yourself that you don't like. Which personally I think is like, you know, the middle ground is often the best in terms of these things. Like the balance of things is always where you find like the most peace, I guess, which is what you're saying. Exactly. And I think that, I mean, we all know how social media and algorithms work. Actually, I recently listened to a Mel Robbins episode that had research that was so interesting that talked about how all of the perspectives on the internet were actually mostly written by like 10% of people. And those 10% of people generally fall in extremes. We are all scared to go against what we think is the popular opinion. So we see those opinions and we decide to ascribe to one of them. And that's how a lot of polarization happens. And I think within the 80s, ADHD community, this polarization is also, at least we all perceive it to be happening,
感觉良好，无论你想把你的目标函数定义为什么。这听起来是一个非常现实的方法。这里没有极端，比如要么这是一种超能力，要么抹杀掉你身上所有你不喜欢的每一件事。我个人认为，在这些事情上，中间立场往往是最好的。事情的平衡往往是你找到最多平静的地方，我想，这就是你在说的。完全正确。而且我认为——我的意思是，我们都知道社交媒体和算法是如何运作的。其实，我最近听了一集梅·罗宾斯（Mel Robbins）的节目，其中有非常有趣的研究探讨了互联网上的所有观点实际上大多是由大约 10% 的人写出来的。而这 10% 的人通常处于极端。我们都害怕违背我们认为的民意。所以我们看到了这些观点，并决定认同其中之一。这就是许多极化现象发生的方式。我认为在 ADHD 社区内，这种极化也在发生，至少我们都觉得它在发生，
but I think there are probably more people in the middle than we think. Yeah. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, we're going to talk some ADHD-friendly strategies for work, for love, for life. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
但我认为中间的人可能比我们想象的要多。好的，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论一些对 ADHD 友好的工作、爱情和生活策略。所以请继续收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信植物油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力导致的。把自己通过一些磨难，你会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在 iHeartRadio
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是 T-W-O-Percent。有两条任何男人都应该遵守的黄金法则。法则一，永远不要招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》（The Girlfriends）的这个新季度里，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗手约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎，所以她们自己采取行动。我说：“哦，见鬼，不。”我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
他会得到应有的惩罚。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时？
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客里找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会把节目搬到这里，剖析发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时可以聊聊快克，但得让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二集讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上，所以。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的时候，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了赢与输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人世间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once.
2023年，前“黄金单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之争，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试并将其交上去，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I had this listener reach out to me the other day and she was like, I really want to know. how I can manage my executive dysfunction as somebody with ADHD.
这是“爱之陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。所以前几天我有一个听众联系我，她说，我真的很想知道。作为一名患有注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）的人，我该如何管理我的执行功能障碍。
And I kind of have to be like, I don't really know, but let me get back to you. Let me ask someone who does know. So what are some of the strategies that you've used to help yourself with deadlines, with focus, with burnout in your career? Yeah. So the first half of my answer is going to be an unpopular one because people always want hacks, but it is so important to first identify where exactly you are going and because you might not need to fix the thing that you think you need to fix. I will first say that and get that out of the
我差不多只能回答说，我其实不太清楚，不过我回头告诉你。让我去问一个知道的人。那么，你在职业生涯中用过哪些策略来帮助自己应对截止日期、专注力和职业倦怠呢？是的。所以我的回答的前半部分可能不会太受欢迎，因为人们总是想要走捷径，但首先要弄清楚你到底要去哪里，这一点至关重要，因为你可能不需要去修复你认为需要修复的东西。我首先要说这一点，并把它摆在
way, even though nobody will listen to me because people always want the hacks. So for me, some of the things that have been the most helpful is, first one is the reframe that not everything needs, not all the solutions need to come from me doing something different internally. A lot of it and it's easier is if you set up your life to be different because then it's a gift that keeps on giving. So that might be setting up your environment in a certain way that is conducive for you to be able to focus. It might be having a specific room in your house where you're working in another room where you've never work in. And then that helps trigger your brain into, I'm in work mode and I'm not in work mode. And it might be having certain systems that your whole family knows about.
前面，尽管没人会听我的，因为人们总是想要捷径。所以对我来说，最有用的一些方法是，第一点是重新构架，并非所有的事情，并非所有的解决方案都需要通过我在内部做出不同的改变来实现。很多情况下，如果你把生活设置得有所不同，其实更容易，因为那样它就会成为一份不断带来回报的礼物。这可能包括以某种方式设置你的环境，有利于你能够集中注意力。它可能是在你的家里有一个特定的房间用来工作，而在另一个你从未工作过的房间里。然后这有助于触发你的大脑进入“我处于工作模式”和“我不在工作模式”的状态。它可能还包括设定一套你们全家人都知道的系统。
So one that is really common is people who work from home, which is a lot of people now when they're writing, they will put a little sign on their door where their kid and their partner all know that this means like I'm in deep writing mode. And so they don't get that distraction. So again, all of these, I'm giving like little examples because it all comes from working back from what your challenges and what your goal is. So if these things don't work for you, I would not also abandon them. You need to think about how you can implement that better in your life. And so that kind of brings me to another one that has been so helpful for me is learning what your motivators are and then injecting that into your work. So for example, for me, novelty and accountability are two of my strongest motivators. So when I can't get something done, I ask myself, okay, what is a way that I can put accountability into it?
所以一个非常常见的例子是那些在家办公的人，现在有很多人在写作时，他们会在门上挂一个小标志，他们的孩子和伴侣都知道这意味着我处于深度写作模式。这样他们就不会受到干扰。所以再次强调，我给出这些小例子是因为这一切都要从倒推你的挑战和你的目标是什么开始。所以如果这些方法对你不适用，我也不建议你放弃它们。你需要考虑如何更好地将其实施到你的生活中。这就让我想到了另一个对我有极大帮助的方法，那就是了解你的动力是什么，然后将其注入到你的工作中。例如，对我来说，新奇感和问责制是我最强大的两个动力。所以当我无法完成某项任务时，我会问自己，好吧，有什么方法可以把问责机制放进去？
Do I have to say with my co-founder that in our next working session he needs to check in with me on this? Like, that's accountability. or for novelty, do I've been wanting to do this thing for a long time and I can't do it. Do I need to do it on Canva and put it in pink instead of doing it on Excel and then just move it later on? So really understanding first what are your motivators and that you can figure out by looking backwards at, let's say a week or even a day if you can't think back at a week and think about what are the moments of the day that you were most excited and most motivated and think through what was there for you. So the most common ones are novelty interest, passion, accountability, urgency. Those are some of the ones that are common for people with ADHD, but you might discover that there are other motivators for you as well. And then the third thing I will say that has been so helpful for me is energy management. So people with ADHD have generally a late set circadian rhythm. They sleep, you want to sleep later and wake up later. We also have more erratic energy bursts throughout the day.
我是不是必须跟我的联合创始人说，在我们下一次的工作会议上，他需要就这个事情向我跟进？看，这就是问责制。或者对于新奇感来说，我是不是一直想做这件事很久了却一直没做？我需不需要在Canva上用粉红色做，而不是在Excel上做，然后再把它移走？所以真正首先理解你的动力是什么，你可以通过回顾过去的一周，或者甚至是一天（如果你想不起一周的话）来找出这一点，想想一天中哪些时刻你是最兴奋、最有动力的，然后思考那些对你意味着什么。所以最常见的动力是新奇感、兴趣、激情、问责制、紧迫感。这些是ADHD人群常见的一些动力，但你可能会发现自己还有其他的动力。然后我要说的第三点对我非常有帮助，那就是能量管理。所以ADHD患者通常有一个较晚的昼夜节律。他们睡觉，你倾向于睡得更晚、醒得更晚。我们在一天中的能量爆发也更加不稳定。
And for a long time, I tried to fight against that. It just, you have these narratives in your head of like, I should be able to be as consistent as everyone else. Like, why can't I work from nine till five? And then there's these other days where you just work for like 12, 14 hours straight. You knock out like a whole weeks of work. And then the next day, you're, you can't do your nine to five.
在很长一段时间里，我都在试图与之抗争。这只是，你脑子里会有这样的声音：“我应该能够像其他人一样保持一致。”“为什么我不能从九点工作到五点？”然后还有一些日子，你连续工作12、14个小时。你一口气敲定了一整周的工作。然后到了第二天，你，你却没法完成你的九到五点的工作。
And you wonder why. Well, because you just knocked out a whole week of work the day before. So really learning what your energy looks like, what times of the day you are energized and maybe putting deep work during that time. what times the day you are in maybe more of a crash vote and maybe you want to do a walk outside because you know that that really brings you up. And also if you're a woman, oftentimes, depending on your hormonal cycle, your energy won't look the same throughout the month. So that awareness again and then matching that awareness with what sort of tasks go in there. And so the
你会纳闷为什么。好吧，因为你昨天刚干完一整周的活儿。所以真正了解你的能量是什么样的，你在一天中的什么时间精力充沛，也许可以把深度工作安排在那个时间。你在一天中的什么时间可能处于崩溃状态，也许你想去外面散步，因为你知道那真的能让你振作起来。而且如果你是女性，通常情况下，根据你的荷尔蒙周期，你的能量在整个月中也会有所不同。所以这种觉察再次发挥作用，然后将这种觉察与适合放在那里的任务类型相匹配。所以
meta kind of message here is really figuring out how you can work with your brain and body instead of fighting against it because oftentimes we fight against it because we think that we need to do things in a way that we've just seen other people do. And when we listen to how other people, like the tips that other people put out there, they're generally from people who are neurotypical, and it generally is the average thing that works for everyone. And if you have ADHD, you're generally not super average. Yeah, probably not. I want to talk about that. this one word you mentioned, which was urgency. And, yeah, how urgency plays a role in ADHD. Personally, I feel like I've read a lot of research that, like, the urgency effect is a lot
这里的核心信息其实是弄清楚如何顺应你的大脑和身体工作，而不是与之对抗，因为我们往往与之对抗，是因为我们认为我们需要以刚刚看到其他人做的方式来做事。当我们听取其他人如何做事时，比如其他人提出的建议，它们通常来自神经典型人群，这通常是适用于所有人的平均做法。如果你有ADHD，你通常不太可能是超级平均的。是的，可能不是。我想谈谈这个。你提到的这个词，就是紧迫感。还有，是的，紧迫感在ADHD中扮演什么角色。就我个人而言，我觉得我读过很多研究，比如紧迫感效应要大得多
stronger. So people with ADHD often prefer working under a tight deadline. How do you suggest people manage that when they also, you know, want to be proactive about not being stressed right up to the time that something is due or doing something the best that they can do it rather than the fastest they can do it. How do they kind of navigate? The complexity of wanting to do it in the moment
强烈。因此，ADHD患者通常更喜欢在紧迫的截止日期下工作。你建议人们如何管理这一点，当他们同时也希望积极主动地避免在某项事情到期前的最后一刻才感到压力，或者以最快而不是最好的方式完成某项工作时？他们该如何驾驭？这种既想在当时有最多肾上腺素时完成它，又想把它做好的复杂心态。
when you have the most adrenaline and wanting to do it well. Yeah, so that's a really tough one because we all know that we do things better, like with ADHD that we do things better at the last minute. But the problem is you probably face a large degree of shame leading up to that moment where for maybe weeks or months you are thinking about the thing and you're thinking about how you're just not doing the thing and how bad you are and how you should be doing it. And that just weighs on you. And that is a really, really large cost. And so
是的，这是一个非常棘手的问题，因为我们都知道我们把事情做得更好，比如患有ADHD的我们把事情在最后一刻做得更好。但问题是，在走到那一刻之前，你可能会面临很大程度的羞耻感，在可能长达数周或数月的时间里，你一直在想着这件事，想着你如何没有去做这件事，想着你是多么糟糕，你本该去做的。这会一直压在你的心头。这是一个非常非常巨大的代价。所以
it's different for each person. If you feel like that cost is not big, not big for you. One option is I do, I have heard of people who are like, I just accept that I do things at the last minute and I will do it. And it depends on what job you have as well. Some people are able to do that. Some people aren't. So I'll first say that like you might not need to solve it. Maybe you need to solve the part where you're ruminating and maybe you need to solve the urgency part. Really figuring out which part you need to solve. But if you do want to not do things at the very last minute, which I generally can't in my job, the way that I've done it is one way is by building in like micro urgency moments using my motivators. So again, similar examples before.
这对每个人来说都是不同的。如果你觉得这个代价不大，对你来说不大。一个选择是，确实，我听说过有人说：“我只是接受我在最后一刻做事，而且我会做。”这也取决于你做什么工作。有些人能做到这一点，有些人做不到。所以我首先要说的是，你可能不需要去解决这个问题。也许你需要解决的是你反刍思维的那部分，也许你需要解决的是紧迫感那部分。真正弄清楚你需要解决哪一部分。但如果你确实不想在最后一刻才做事情，这在我的工作中通常做不到，我采用的方法之一是通过利用我的动力来建立微紧迫感时刻。所以再次回到之前的例子。
If I know that there's a big project that's due, I try not to make. I try, when I do the project planning part, I try to build in multiple smaller urgency moments for me. So I will do a meeting maybe a quarter way through where I know I need someone's feedback and they're waiting for my for what I have. And we've communicated ahead of time that on this day, we're going to talk about this thing. And that for me is enough for me to be able to do that quarter of the work because I have that preset out for me. And if you have the, I would say privilege, let's say if you have an assistant or if using some of AI tools, having them be able to do that for you because they know that you need that and setting the meeting, if there's a meeting in my calendar and I know everyone's different for me,
如果我知道有一个大项目要交，我尽量不做。我试着，在做项目规划部分时，我试着为自己建立多个较小的紧迫感时刻。所以我会在项目进行到大约四分之一的时候开个会，我知道我需要某人的反馈，他们在等待我的成果。我们提前沟通好了，在哪一天我们要讨论这件事。对我和这部分工作的完成来说，这就足够了，因为我已经提前为自己预设好了。如果你有，我想说是特权吧，比方说如果你有一个助理或者使用一些人工智能工具，让他们能够为你做到这一点，因为他们知道你需要这个并安排会议，如果我的日历上有一个会议，每个人都不一样对我而言，
if there's a meeting in my calendar, I will prepare for it. If there's no meeting in my calendar, I won't prepare for it. And if there's a meeting with someone else, I will more likely prepare for a while. So just really pulling on all of those your own motivators and then building in extra urgency moments is really helpful. And then another thing is really just a lot of the times we do something, let's say, we wait until the last minute and then we do this thing really stressfully and then we say, oh my gosh, I'm never doing this again. This was so stressful. I hate this. And then within a month, you forget. You totally forget that learning. That is so common, not just for this example,
如果我的日历上有一个会议，我会为之做准备。如果我的日历上没有会议，我就不会做准备。如果这是一场与他人的会议，我会更有可能提前准备一段时间。所以真正调动你所有的个人动力，然后建立额外的紧迫感时刻真的很有帮助。然后另一件事其实是，很多时候我们做了一件事，比方说，我们等到最后一刻，然后充满压力地做完这件事，然后我们说：“噢天哪，我再也不这样了。这压力太大了。我讨厌这样。”然后在不到一个月的时间里，你就忘了。你完全忘记了那个教训。这太常见了，不仅仅适用于这个例子，
but so many examples. So I think one thing that's also really important is finding your own way of making sure you capture the things that you've learned in the past. And so, I mean, with Mia, you shimmer, but it's not just negative and like learnings, but also wins. So I have a folder in my phone and in my laptop and in my email. I have three different ones that I just capture like testimonials, photos. When someone sends me an Instagram comment that says that like my ex video has changed their life and because I need reminders of those things because on days where I'm not doing so hot, I will forget and I'll be like, wow, like all this is for nothing and nobody, I've not changed
还有很多很多的例子。所以我认为同样非常重要的一件事是，找到你自己的方法，确保你记录下过去学到的东西。所以，我的意思是，用Mia的话来说，就是闪光点，不仅是消极的教训，还有胜利。所以我的手机、笔记本电脑和电子邮件里都有一个文件夹。我有三个不同的文件夹，用来收集那些感言和照片。当有人在Instagram上发评论说我的某个视频改变了他们的人生，因为我需要这些东西的提醒，因为在我状态不佳的日子里，我会忘记，我会想：“哇，这一切都是为了什么，没有人，我没有改变
anyone's life and I've just been here working myself off for no reason. And so I get these narratives. in my head and when I can just look at these pictures or look at these messages, it reminds me and kind of grounds me in the past because it's harder for people with ADHD to remember the past, especially when they're in like a emotionally dysregulated moment. Yeah, I can only imagine how tricky that would be just being like, oh, I can never remember a good thing that anyone said to me. Like the intersection of like self-esteem in ADHD is like a whole other conversation. I had a friend who actually speaking of like the urgency stuff and meeting
任何人的生活，我只是在这里拼命工作，毫无意义。”所以我的脑子里会出现这些消极的想法，而当我只需看一眼这些照片或看一眼这些消息时，它就会提醒我，并让我扎根于过去，因为患有ADHD的人很难记住过去，特别是当他们处于情绪失调的时刻时。是的，我完全可以想象那是多么棘手，就好像“哦，我永远记不住任何人对我说过的好话”。自尊心与ADHD的交集完全是另一个话题了。我有个朋友，其实说到紧迫感和会议
deadlines at the start of every single semester when we were at uni, he would go through all the core syllabuses and then put all of the deadlines in his in his calendar three days beforehand. And he kind of was like, I'm going to use my memory, the fact that I know I'm not going to have great memory recall to like, and some of them he'd do like three, some of them he'd do like five, Some of them he'd do like two days beforehand. One day beforehand, he was like, I'm just going to, you know, go and, you know, trust that I'm not going to remember which ones I did for which of these. I'm just going to trust what's in my calendar and get it done at this date so that by the time that rolls around, like, I get to feel the urgency. I finish the work and then I have like a day to edit or have like a day to fix it.
我们在大学时，每学期刚开学的时候有截止日期，他会把所有核心课程的大纲过一遍，然后把所有的截止日期提前三天放进他的日历里。他当时的想法是，我要利用我的记忆力，利用我深知自己记性不太好的这一点，其中有些他会提前三天，有些会提前五天，有些会提前两天。提前一天的时候，他会想，我只需（你知道的）去相信我不会记得自己为这些课程里的哪一个做了什么。我只需相信日历里的内容，并在这一天完成它，这样等截止日期到来的时候，我能感受到紧迫感，完成工作，然后我就会有一天的时间来修改或纠正。
Or I just submit and I'm like happily surprised by the fact that the deadline hasn't passed yet. I feel like for some people that wouldn't work, but I saw it work incredibly well for him. It was like, honestly, I was like watching it being like, how do you just lie to yourself like that? And like it was so weird. Like he knew that it was a lie and he would still believe it. Even like it was just the most interesting thing that he'd found like this hack for his brain. I love that. Yeah, he's, I mean, he's externalizing his memory and also once he gets there, even though he knows, it's still a lot of effort to do the calculation.
或者我直接提交，然后惊喜地发现截止日期还没过。我觉得对某些人来说这可能行不通，但我看到它在他身上效果好得惊人。老实说，我看着这一幕时心想：你怎么能对自己撒这种谎呢？这太诡异了。他明知这是一个谎言，却依然深信不疑。甚至这简直是最有趣的事情，他为自己的大脑找到了这种小诀窍。我太喜欢了。是的，他，我的意思是，他在将记忆外包，而且一旦到了那个时候，尽管他心知肚明，这仍然需要耗费大量精力去计算。
and all of that. So it's kind of like when I think a lot of people did this. It's not just an ADHD thing. But when I was younger, my clock was always five minutes ahead. I put all my clocks five minutes ahead. And I knew it was a lie, but you just don't like, I'm not constantly calculating the time. So I just end up getting to places. I think five minutes. I thought I would be there five minutes early, but then I'd be there on time, which is perfect. Oh my God, perfect. Yeah. See, I never did that because I just knew I was like, well, that's not the truth. But then again, like I had. executive function where I could just be like, oh, I'll just get there 10 minutes early. So it's like interesting how like maybe, yeah, it's just so interesting how different people do those things. I want to talk about love. I want to start by talking about rejection sensitivity. This is a word that I hear in regards to ADHD all the time. I've done an episode on it before. I have, I think, a pretty general knowledge of it. Can you talk us through it? Why is it so common amongst people with ADHD. And I guess my third question, so sorry, three questions at once.
以及所有这些。所以这就有点像，我觉得很多人都这样做过。这不单单是ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍）特有的问题。但自我更小的时候起，我的时钟总是快五分钟。我把我所有的时钟都调快了五分钟。我知道这是一个谎言，但你就是不喜欢，我不是在不断地计算时间。所以我最终还是会到达目的地。我觉得五分钟。我原以为自己会早到五分钟，但最后我刚好准时到达，这太完美了。天哪，太完美了。是的。你看，我从来不那样做，因为我当时就知道，嗯，那不是真的。但话又说回来，我有执行功能，我可以告诉自己，噢，我会早到10分钟。所以这很有趣，也许，是的，不同的人如何做这些事情真的非常有趣。我想谈谈爱情。我想从拒绝敏感度开始谈起。这是我在谈论ADHD时经常听到的一个词。我以前做过一期关于它的节目。我想我对它有一个相当笼统的了解。你能给我们详细讲讲吗？为什么它在ADHD人群中如此普遍？我想我的第三个问题是，非常抱歉，同时问了三个问题。
How can people manage it? But firstly, what is it? Why is it common? And then we can talk about tips for managing it. So rejection sensitivity dysphoria, which is commonly known as RSD, is essentially a phenomenon, I guess you can call it, where people with ADHD will feel like they're rejected by other people or feel like there's negative sentiment coming towards them. And it's defined as like real or perceived rejection.
人们该如何应对它？但首先，它是什么？为什么它很普遍？然后我们可以讨论应对它的技巧。因此，拒绝敏感性烦躁（Rejection sensitivity dysphoria），通常被称为RSD，本质上是一种现象，我想你可以称之为有ADHD的人会觉得自己被别人拒绝，或者觉得有人对他们抱有消极情绪。它被定义为真实的或感知到的拒绝。
So oftentimes it falls in that second category of perceived. And it's generally created through, well, one, emotional dysregulation of us just the moment we feel something, we like jump on that feeling and then it becomes bigger and bigger. And then we're kind of just swimming in that feeling. Or, or I guess and it's also because we've had an entire lifetime of people telling us that we were wrong or we're doing it the wrong way. And then we've internalized that and then we can. continue to tell ourselves that. And so whenever there's like a small, I guess, like signal, you feel like you've done something wrong. And so for me, for example, like, whenever I'm in an argument with someone work or relationships, I will always think that I'm wrong, like 100% of
所以它往往属于第二种情况，即感知到的拒绝。它通常是通过以下方式产生的，嗯，第一，我们的情绪失调，就在我们感受到某种情绪的那一刻，我们就会扑向那种情绪，然后它就会变得越来越大。然后我们就在那种情绪中随波逐流。或者，或者我想也是因为我们经历了一生中别人告诉我们我们错了，或者我们的做法不对。然后我们把这些内化了，接着我们就会不断地告诉自己这些。因此，每当出现一点点，我想，类似信号的东西时，你就会觉得自己做错了什么。所以对我和我的经历来说，每当我与工作中的某个人或在恋爱关系中发生争论时，我总是认为自己是错的，百分之百
the time. That's my immediate reaction. Sometimes people need to convince me. And this has happened in relationships where they're like, no, no, like, let's have a conversation about this. there's no right or wrong. We're just trying to get to a understanding. And so I've been unlearning that. I'm just like, oh, no, I must have done something wrong. Like, you must hate me. So it is from most people with ADHD, this lifelong unlearning. And especially in, like, logically, I know in people's situations, it's, there's no, there's often not like a wrong, but I just feel that way. And so I guess your second part of the question of like what people can do with it. Yeah. One really, for me, that's been most helpful and I've been working on with coaching that comes up for a lot of our members too, is really understanding like what your triggers are and what sort of situations these come up with come up in the most.
都是我的错。这是我的本能反应。有时人们需要说服我。这种情况在恋爱关系中发生过，他们会说：不，不，让我们好好谈谈这件事。没有所谓的对与错。我们只是试图达成共识。所以我一直在改掉这个习惯。我只会想：噢，不，我一定做错了什么。你一定恨我。所以对大多数ADHD患者来说，这是一个需要花一辈子去改掉的习惯。尤其是在逻辑上，我知道在人们的情况下，没有错，通常也没有对错之分，但我就是有这种感觉。所以我想你的第二个问题是人们可以对此做些什么。是的。对我来说最有用的一点，也是我一直在通过教练指导来解决的问题，这在我们的许多会员身上也经常出现，那就是真正理解你的触发点是什么，以及这些情况最容易在什么样的场景下发生。
And this actually goes for not just RSD, but also impulsivity. It's the same thing where I do a lot of impulsive stupid things and I don't realize it's wrong and it's hurt people until after it's done and people communicate it to me. And for both of those things, what I worked on with my coach is separately for those two things, understanding. What situations do those commonly happen in? And just the awareness of that when you're about to step into a situation like that, like, for example, with impulsivity, maybe it's drinking. And you can have that pep talk with yourself to say, okay, like, I'm entering this situation with awareness. And so it could be awareness that your RSD might be triggered. It could be awareness that you might do something impulsive so that you, you know,
这实际上不仅适用于RSD，也适用于冲动性。情况是一样的，我做了很多冲动愚蠢的事情，直到事情做完别人向我传达之后，我才意识到这是不对的并且已经伤害了别人。对于这两件事，我和我的教练分开针对这两件事所做的工作是去了解。这些情况通常在什么情况下发生？只要你在即将进入这样一种情境时具备这种意识，比如，就冲动性而言，也许是饮酒。你可以对自己进行一番心理建设，说：好的，我带着觉察进入这种情境。因此，这可能是意识到你的RSD可能会被触发。这可能是意识到你可能会做一些冲动的事情，以便你，你知道的，
you can put, and it's the same solution again, you can put that pause. So when someone says something and you immediately, your brain starts spiraling, you need to get into the practice of putting the pause. And same with impulsivity. When you're about to have an impulsive moment and you just need to figure out how to put the pause. And so the best thing you can do for yourself is understanding when that generally happens because it's not, it's not random. For each person, it's going to be in different situations where that happens. And so really just knowing in this situation, these sorts of conversations generally make me feel this way. And if that happens, I'm going to do this. And if you have that plan beforehand when you're calm and collected and
你可以按下暂停键，这也是同样的解决方案，你可以按下暂停键。所以当有人说了一些话，你的大脑立刻开始螺旋式上升时，你需要练习按下暂停键。冲动也是如此。当你要经历一个冲动的时刻时，你只需要弄清楚如何按下暂停键。因此，你能为自己做的最好的事情就是了解这种情况通常何时发生，因为它不是，它不是随机的。对每个人来说，发生这种情况的情境都是不同的。所以真正要做的就是明白，在这种情境下，这类对话通常会让我产生这种感觉。如果发生这种情况，我打算这么做。如果你在自己平静、镇定的时候提前制定了这个计划，并且
you've written that down, ideally, I used to have, I think when I first started this exercise, I used to have a sticky note. And I would like put it in my closet where I would like get dressed before going out where I would more likely to drink. And so really just like putting it where you would need to see it to remind yourself of that. And over time, you'll need to remind yourself less because your brain is kind of trained to go trigger and then thought and then like being able to block that thought. It's like putting yourself in a waiting room. That's like what that sounds like to me. I'm like, okay, before we react or like before we do something like forcing, forcing yourself to like sit with it for a little bit. Exactly. And knowing when you might need to be in that waiting room because
把它们写下来，最好是这样。我记得当我刚开始做这个练习时，我过去常有一张便签。我会把它贴在我的衣橱上，我在出门前会在那里穿衣服，而我那时更容易喝酒。所以实际上就是把它放在你需要看到的地方，以此来提醒自己。随着时间的推移，你需要提醒自己的次数就会减少，因为你的大脑已经接受了这样的训练：触发，然后产生想法，然后能够阻止这个想法。这就像把自己放在一个候诊室里。听起来给我的感觉就是这样的。我想，好吧，在我们做出反应之前，或者在我们做某事之前，强迫自己，强迫自己在那里坐上一小会儿。完全正确。并且知道你什么时候可能需要进入那个候诊室，因为
when you're emotionally dysregulated, you might not be able to put yourself in that waiting room. So like basically giving your brain an autopilot. saying like, if this happens, I go to a waiting room. Yeah. It's like a if then. Which I love. And I just like can't imagine what it would feel like to be like, everybody who says something slightly rude or just slightly off or not even like you just
当你情绪失调时，你可能无法让自己进入那个候诊室。所以基本上就是给你的大脑开启自动驾驶模式。就像在说：如果发生这种情况，我就去候诊室。是的。这就像一个“如果……就……”的条件句。我太喜欢了。我简直无法想象那种感觉会是什么样，就好像每个人说的话都有点粗鲁，或者稍微有点不对劲，甚至都不是，你只是把它们
temperate them as like not liking you. My friend actually told me about this rule, which is like the 25% rule, which is there is like actually only a small amount of people, maybe 25% of people who you will never convinced not to like you. Oh, who you will never convinced to like you. Sorry, that's what I should say. Never convinced to like you. And that's like one in four, which might sound like a huge number, but it's just kind of
归结为不喜欢你。我的朋友实际上跟我讲过这个规则，也就是“25%法则”，意思是实际上只有一小部分人，大概25%的人，你永远无法说服他们喜欢你。哦，也就是你永远无法说服他们喜欢你。抱歉，我应该这么说。永远无法说服他们喜欢你。这大约是四分之一，这听起来可能是一个巨大的数字，但它其实有点
like doing the math of like actually not every single person could possibly not like me. But also, I'm down to accept that maybe like a quarter of them will. And that's just a certainty that everyone's going to find themselves in. So I don't know if that's also helpful, but yeah, it would just be wild. Yeah, and I think the other thing is I often, whenever I have a feeling, RSD is one of them. I often think that it's less so a reflection on the other person and it's usually a reflection on myself. So I would say the other tip that I would have is if you think that everyone's having some sort of negative thought towards yourself, it might not be, but I would challenge to think if you maybe have that negative thought towards yourself.
像是做数学题，实际上并不是每个人都不可能不喜欢我。但同时，我也接受可能四分之一的人会不喜欢我。这是每个人都会遇到的必然情况。所以我不知道这是否有帮助，但是的，这太疯狂了。是的，我认为另一件事是，每当我有一种感觉时，RSD就是其中之一。我经常认为这与其说是对另一个人的反映，不如说是对自我的反映。所以我给出的另一个建议是，如果你认为每个人都对你有某种消极的想法，可能事实并非如此，但我建议你反思一下，自己是不是对也有这样的消极想法。
And so if that is the case, then you need to do the work to be able to reinforce your strengths, reinforce past wins to really build up your self-confidence, which is it's a practice of building self-confidence of continuing to put yourself out there and seeing that things are going to go well for you and that you can handle these situations. And so as you build up your self-confidence, you will find that these situations, you'll less likely feel like other people don't like you because you back yourself so hard. hard and that's such a long journey right but like you want to get to the point where you back yourself so hard that you wouldn't think that they don't like you but even if you had all the signals and
如果是这样的话，你就需要做一些工作来巩固自己的优势，巩固过去的成功，从而真正建立自信，这其实是一个培养自信的过程——不断地走出去，看到事情会朝着对你有利的方向发展，并且你能够应付这些情况。因此，随着你自信心的建立，你会发现遇到这些情况时，你不太会觉得别人不喜欢你，因为你对自己有着极强的底气。这种底气十足的状态，漫长的一段旅程，对吧？但你想要达到的境界是，你对自己的底气十足，以至于你不会觉得他们不喜欢你；即便你得到了所有的信号，并且
they didn't like you it wouldn't even impact you because it doesn't matter because you back yourself so much yeah which i love i'm like this is something i find even as someone without ADHD it's like the things that sting the most of the things that you think might be true exactly and that's like that's something that is for everybody so it's like yes where is that pain coming from from. I want to talk about a bit more about relationships as well and maybe some of the common hurdles or pitfalls that people with ADHD might find when they're falling in love or even in friendship. Yeah. So I did a whole series called ADHD Girl Feels and ADHD Goal dates on this. So it's really fun if you want to check it out. But I think like in the early stages, one of the
他们确实不喜欢你，这也根本不会对你产生影响，因为它毫无关系，因为你对自己的信心太足了。是的，我太喜欢了。我发现，即使是对一个没有ADHD的人来说，最刺痛你的往往是你自己也觉得可能是真的那些事情。没错，这是每个人都会有的感受，所以这就变成了：这种痛苦究竟是从何而来的？我还想再多聊聊恋爱关系，以及ADHD患者在坠入爱河甚至交友时可能会遇到的一些常见障碍或陷阱。是的。为此我做过一整个系列的节目，叫《ADHD女孩的感觉》和《ADHD女孩的约会》，如果你想去看看的话，真的非常有趣。但我认为在早期阶段，其中一个
really common ones, which is a interesting one because I do this and I've been done this too, is definitely around love bombing. This comes up so frequently because it's related to emotional dysregulation in that when we fall for someone, it's very common that we fall for them like really hard and then we ignore all the signals, even if there's red flags or whatever it is. And we pour so much love in them that it can also sometimes scare people away. So even in a relationship where it could have worked, maybe you just freak them out because you came on too hard. And so that in itself can be a challenge, but also then there's this transition of like when you finish the initial disregulated love bombing, it can feel jarring to your partner when you suddenly like change the way that you act. And I know everyone goes through a little bit of this, but I think within each years we feel this more and it's very common this whole love bombing thing.
非常常见的现象——这是一个有趣的现象，因为我自己也这样做过，并且也经历过——绝对是关于“爱的轰炸”（love bombing）。这种情况非常频繁地出现，因为它与情绪失调有关，当我们爱上某个人时，我们往往会深深地爱上对方，然后忽略所有的信号，即使有危险信号或其他什么情况。我们在他们身上倾注了太多的爱，有时甚至会把人吓跑。因此，即使是一段本可以成功的恋爱关系，也许你只是把对方吓坏了，因为你的攻势太猛了。所以这本身就是一个挑战，但除此之外，还有这样一种转变：当你结束了最初失调的“爱的轰炸”期，当你突然改变行事方式时，你的伴侣可能会感到震惊。我知道每个人都会经历一点这样的阶段，但我认为我们ADHD人群对此感受更深，这种“爱的轰炸”现象非常普遍。
I think Lovebop is obviously not the official term for it. Yeah. But everything gets heightened and this is a very sensitive moment where it is sometimes helpful to be aware of that and then make sure you're, I mean, it's your choice if you want to try to control it and slow it down. I think a lot of people give advice to slow it down. I actually just find it important to communicate for me.
我认为“爱的轰炸”显然不是官方术语。是的，但一切都被放大了，这是一个非常敏感的时刻，意识到这一点有时会很有帮助，然后确保你——我的意思是，如果你想试着控制它并放慢节奏，这是你的选择。我认为很多人给出的建议是放慢节奏。而我实际上只是觉得，对我来说，进行沟通很重要。
I actually enjoy the really strong I'm falling head over my heels, heals feeling. I just will explain to the person that this happens to me. I think this is what's happening and just keeping the communication open so that they're aware that I'm aware of this and we're kind of making a decision together. But I know a lot of people do give the advice to, there's tactics to essentially like kind of like draw that that love period out longer so that you can be able to explore things in a more calm way. So I think it's really person dependent. and obviously there's no right answer. And what do you think, or from experience, what happens after like the love high kind of crashes?
我其实很享受那种深深坠入爱河、神魂颠倒的感觉。我只会向对方解释这种现象会发生在我身上。我认为这正是正在发生的事情，并保持开放的沟通，让他们知道我意识到了这一点，我们在某种程度上共同做出决定。但我知道很多人确实给出了这样的建议，有一些策略本质上可以拉长那个热恋期，这样你就能以一种更平静的方式去探索事物。所以我觉得这真的因人而异，而且显然没有标准答案。根据你的经验，当热恋的高潮消退之后，会发生什么？
Like I feel like that state where, you know, there may be love bombing, there may be intensity, like can only last for so long. What happens then? Is it a case of like you get bored or you get confused or you think you've fallen out of love with them? Yeah, what does that feeling feel? like. A lot of the times it does, it does feel like boredom. And I think that there's a process of figuring out if it's because of the person in your relationship that isn't actually right and you were just stuck in all the feelings or if you haven't found a way to potentially value and fall in love with the other parts of a relationship, which are maybe not the same as the parts of the relationship
我觉得那种状态，你知道的，可能存在“爱的轰炸”，可能存在强烈的情感，这种状态只能维持一段时间。接下来会发生什么？是不是会出现你觉得无聊、困惑，或者以为自己已经不爱对方的情况？是的，那种感觉是什么样的？很多时候，它确实感觉像是无聊。我认为这个过程需要你去弄清楚，这究竟是因为这段关系中的人其实并不合适，你只是陷入了所有的情感之中；还是说你还没有找到一种方法去欣赏并爱上恋爱关系中的其他部分，而这些部分可能与恋爱
in the beginning. And it also, I think a lot of, of the times too because you fell so hard you weren't thinking very critically about things like for example most of my neurotypical friends I actually know that they have this like list of like non-negotiables and things are looking for in a relationship and all those things and I always thought it was kind of interesting because I was like oh there's no point in me making that because I've actually never chosen a relationship that I've been in I've just fallen into it I don't know why I would have that list when would I use it but I did actually recently create the list because my co-founder who is neurotypical he had his list and we were talking about it and I was like okay I'll try to create the list and so it was helpful going through the thought
初期的部分不尽相同。而且我认为很多时候，由于你爱得太深，你并没有进行非常批判性的思考，比如，我大部分神经典型（neurotypical）的朋友，我其实知道他们有一份“不可妥协事项”清单，列出了他们在恋爱关系中寻找的特质以及所有这些事情。我一直觉得这挺有趣的，因为我想：噢，我没必要去弄那个清单，因为我实际上从来没有刻意选择过我经历过的任何一段恋爱关系，我只是顺其自然地陷入其中。我为什么要有那个清单呢？我什么时候会用到它呢？但我的确在最近创建了这份清单，因为我的联合创始人是个神经典型，他有一份自己的清单，我们在谈论这个时，我就想：好吧，我会试着列一个清单。
process around it but I'm just not sure if I would use it in the same way that are able to use it in the same way because I'm not as level-headed going into a relationship yeah which I feel it could be both so much fun and super scary if you're like Like, I'm just here for the ride. Like, wherever this goes, like, I kind of know I might not be in control for the first little bit, which I don't know. You said you enjoyed the feeling, so it kind of sounds fun. Yeah. I do enjoy it.
经历这个思考过程对我有帮助，但我只是不确定我是否会像他们那样去使用它，或者是否能够以那种方式使用它，因为我在进入一段感情时没有那么冷静。是的，我觉得这既可以非常有趣又超级吓人，如果你觉得：好吧，我只是来享受这段旅程的。无论这走向何方，我大概知道自己在最初的一段时间里可能无法掌控，虽然我不知道。你说你很享受这种感觉，所以听起来挺好玩的。是的，我确实很享受。
But I definitely have gone through phases where I had, like, pretty strong fears of what if I can never be in a long-term relationship? What if I'm only good at this beginning part? So those are definitely things that I have thought about. I'm currently in my first ever ADHD-AIDS-D relationship. I've always been ADHD near our typical relationships. So I'm starting to change my mind about things because we talk really openly about ADHD symptoms and we communicate through it. So it's felt different. So I'm hopeful.
但我确实经历过这样一些阶段：我非常强烈地担心，如果我永远无法维持一段长期的恋爱关系怎么办？如果我只擅长开头这一段怎么办？这些绝对是我思考过的问题。我目前正处于我有生以来第一段ADHD与ADHD的恋爱关系中。我以前经历的都是ADHD与神经典型人士的恋爱关系。所以我开始改变对一些事情的看法，因为我们会非常公开地谈论ADHD的症状，并通过沟通来解决问题。所以感觉有所不同。因此我感到充满希望。
I'm hopeful for you as well. Okay, we're going to take one more short break. But when we return, I'm going to kind of talk a bit more. I want to talk more about this relationship that you're. are in and how you're managing it and also, you know, some tips for people who are late diagnosed and just tips for people in their 20s in general. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
我也为你感到充满希望。好的，我们要进行短暂的休息。但当我们回来时，我打算再多聊一点。我想更多地聊聊你目前的这段感情以及你是如何处理它的，还有给那些被确诊较晚的人的一些建议，以及给20多岁人群的一般性建议。所以请继续收听。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
体能以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，透过那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上所恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
听听《2%》。就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 T-W-O-Percent。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《女朋友们》的这个新季度中，“天哪，这居然是同一个男人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。“我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。”于是，她们决定亲自采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上拍了拍小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊可卡因，只是想让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师——
Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough
基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，但我们仍在追逐，却不知道什么时候才算够。
because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上当个好人很重要，还是你当好人只是因为害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难成长》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克特发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。“你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。“我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。”阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。“女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉——”
on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so you mentioned during your first ADHD-A-D-D-Hadish relationship. How is that different from dating somebody who is neurotypical, if you want to talk about it, of course? Yeah, yeah, of course. I have thought about this a lot and I actually, coming into this relationship, I thought that I had to be in an ADHD neurotypical relationship. One, me and my co-founder is neurotypical. So even from a business perspective, I've always thought, okay, we have different skills.
——涉嫌欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。好的，那么你在之前提到过，在你的第一段 ADHD-ADHD 关系中。这与和神经典型的人约会有什么不同，如果你想谈谈的话，当然？对，对，当然。我对此想了很多，实际上，在进入这段关系之前，我以为我必须经历一段 ADHD 与神经典型者的关系。第一，我和我的联合创始人是神经典型的。所以即使从商业角度来看，我一直认为，好吧，我们有不同的技能。
We have different strengths. And together we are stronger. And I do think, I still do believe in that, but I used to believe that it couldn't be a different way. And so now I'm in an ADHD, ADHD relationship. And there's different pros and cons. I think obviously there's certain things where we are both going to be back. at and therefore it's going to be harder to get done like chores or long doing things around the house but i think the pros is that there's so many things i didn't realize until i was in a
我们有不同的优势。我们在一起会更强大。我确实认为，我依然相信这一点，但我过去认为不可能有别的相处方式。而现在我处于一段 ADHD 与 ADHD 的关系中。这有不同的优缺点。我认为显然在某些方面我们都会不擅长，因此事情会更难完成，比如家务或者做家里长期的杂务，但我认为优点是有很多事情，直到我身处——
ADHD-80s relationship that i used to need to at least explain and try to explain myself because it looked like i was either being lazy or careless or i didn't love them or whatever there's a lot of misinterpretations or even worse than that a lot of the times i would not even try to explain i would just feel like I was going to get judged for something and therefore just not do it. Versus now, I think in a lot of situations, we will just talk about things. Like the communication will just be more open and I will be more comfortable sharing things because I know that she'll have like a similar, either a similar perspective or or at least understand that perspectives are different.
一段 ADHD 与 ADHD 的关系中，我才意识到我以前需要至少去解释并试图解释自己，因为看起来我要么是在偷懒，要么是粗心大意，或者我不爱他们，诸如此类。有很多误解，甚至更糟糕的是，很多时候我甚至不会去尝试解释，我只是觉得我会因为某事而被评判，因此干脆不做。而现在，我认为在许多情况下，我们只会谈论事情。就像沟通会更开放，我会更乐于分享事情，因为我知道她会有类似的视角，或者至少明白大家的视角是不同的。
Yeah. I feel like it would be so comforting just being like, oh, I don't have. have to, I don't, like, you have some of the same knowledge as me. And we can laugh about things that, we can laugh at ourselves rather than laughing at the other person. But yeah, it's been, it's also been hard for me to untangle because this is also my first queer relationship. So some things, I'm like, I'm not sure if this is coming from the interesting part or the I'm dating a woman part. So it's like, is it easy? because it's ADHD or because like women just tend to have more planning skills. Yeah, that's interesting. Or like tend to just like be easier to work with slash be with. Yeah. Yeah. It's like I
是的。我觉得如果能有这种感觉会非常安慰，比如，哦，我不用，我不用，就像，你和我拥有一些相同的知识。我们可以对事情付之一笑，我们可以自嘲而不是嘲笑对方。但是，是的，这也是我很难理清的一点，因为这也是我的第一段酷儿关系。所以有些事情，我会想，我不确定这是源于有趣的部分，还是源于我在和女人约会的部分。所以就像，它是变简单了，是因为我们都有 ADHD，还是因为女性往往有更好的规划能力？是的，这很有趣。或者就像更容易一起共事/相处。是的。是的。就像我
wish from a scientific perspective, if these could have happened in two steps, that would have been helpful. But no, that's so funny. I love that you wanted a control group. That's so me. I don't, I get what you mean. This is another thing that's like my second final question as we're coming to the end of this episode. how do you deal with or how do you think people with ADHD can deal with this feeling that they are too much, that they are too much for love, they're too much for the workplace, they're too much in friendship, they're too much for their family. Have you like kind of had to overcome that in your own life?
希望从科学的角度来看，如果这些能分成两步发生就好了，那会很有帮助。不过，不，这太搞笑了。我喜欢你想要一个对照组。太像我了。我不是，我明白你的意思。这是另一件事，就像作为本集接近尾声时的倒数第二个问题，你如何处理，或者你认为 ADHD 患者如何应对这种感觉：觉得自己“太多了”，觉得自己在爱情中表现得太多，在职场中太多，在友情中太多，对家人来说也太多。你是否在自己的生活中克服过这种感觉？
And like how did you kind of go about it? Yeah. So I always thought I was too much. And I just, as I mentioned in the beginning, I kind of just accepted that I was a bad, kid. And even in my first job in consulting, I was told that, oh, your work is really great, but you're, I think even some point they said I was doing too much. I was doing a lot of pro bono and volunteering stuff. And they're like, that's not the point of your job. And then I was doing too much like social and culture stuff. And also I wasn't being like reliable and consistent
以及你是如何应对的？是的。所以我一直觉得自己“太多了”。正如我在开始时提到的，我只是接受了自己是个坏孩子。甚至在我咨询的第一份工作里，我被告知，哦，你的工作真的很棒，但你，我想甚至有一次他们说我做得太多了。我做了很多无偿的公益和志愿者工作。他们说，这不是你工作的重点。然后我做了太多社交和文化方面的事情。而且我还不够可靠和稳定。
enough. So I think it's a big, it's actually a mix of being too much and not enough, which is kind of ironic, but you constantly feel like you're in one of those two buckets. You're either too much or not enough. And so for me, one big, the thing that has been really helpful, honestly, has just been changing my environment. As a entrepreneur, you're never too much. You're expected to be too much. So you're expected to push the boundaries. You're expected to be really inspirational and loud and be doing a bunch of things. And so that really helped because the expectation is just different. And then the other thing is like speaking about relationships, even in relationships I always felt like I was either too much or not enough. And I think in this current relationship, we've had this conversation
所以我觉得这是一个很大的问题，实际上这是“太多了”和“远远不够”的混合体，这有点讽刺，但你经常觉得你处于这两个极端之一。你要么太多，要么不够。所以对我来说，一个很大的、真正有帮助的事情，老实说，就是改变我的环境。作为一个创业者，你永远不会嫌多。人们期望你“太多”。所以你被期望去突破界限。你被期望非常具有启发性、声音洪亮并且同时做很多事情。所以这真的很有帮助，因为大家的期望就是不同的。然后另一件事是谈到关系，即使在亲密关系中，我也总是觉得自己要么太多，要么不够。我认为在目前这段关系中，我们已经进行过多次这样的对话。
many times. And I think it's because she also has ADHD, but she's also too much, too much, unquote. And so I think it just changes the barometer because everything is contextual, right? Too much is like too much for what? Too much compared to neurotypical people, too much compared to what's expected of you. So if you can change the comparison point, then you no longer become too much. You just become different than other people around you, but everyone's different in a different way. So I think if you have the privilege to change the context around you, the environment around you, that's generally easier. And because a lot of members who come to us, even at Schimmer, they'll say things like, oh, I just like want to be productive because I'm not productive enough. I'm not
而且我认为这是因为她也有 ADHD，但她也“太多了”，引号里的“太多”。所以我觉得这改变了衡量标准，因为一切都是有语境的，对吧？“太多”是指对什么来说太多？与神经典型的人相比太多，与对你的期望相比太多。所以如果你能改变对比的点，那么你就不再是“太多”。你只是变得和周围其他人不同，但每个人都有不同的不同之处。所以如果你有特权去改变你周围的语境、周围的环境，这通常会更容易。因为许多来到我们这里的会员，甚至在 Schimmer，他们会说这样的话，哦，我只是想变得高效，因为我产出不够高。我不够——
organized enough. And then turns out what actually would make them happy is just placing them in a different environment or a different job or having a different sort of system, so such that they don't need to do all the like high horsepower work that they think is required to be able to get to where they want. So really questioning those aspects. And then the other piece, which I know I've touched on a lot, is just finding your way to build up self-assurance and self-confidence. Yeah. And there's like the little tactics I talked about about, about keeping your wins really handy, keeping, making sure the people around you are really supportive. And a lot of it starts with leadership as well. If you are gassing up the people around you
有条理。然后事实证明，实际上能让他们快乐的是把他们置于不同的环境、不同的工作中，或者让他们有一套不同的系统，这样他们就不需要去做所有那些他们以为达到目标所必需的高强度工作了。所以要真正质疑这些方面。然后另一部分，我知道我谈了很多，就是找到建立自信和自我确信的方法。是的，还有我谈到的小技巧，比如把你的胜利成果随时放在手边，确保你周围的人都非常支持你。而且很多事情也是从领导力开始的。如果你在周围人面前加油鼓劲——
and leading by example and they're going to move in about it, they're probably going to gas you up back. So a lot of the times we sit here wishing that like the world was different. But if you just do how, I mean, there's like the cliche, like treat other people how you want to be treated. But it works. It works. It's a cliche for a reason. The best way to make someone do something that you want them to do is for you to do it. And they see it. They're like, oh, okay.
并以身作则，他们因此而行动，他们很可能会反过来为你加油鼓劲。所以很多时候我们坐在这里，希望世界能有所不同。但如果你只是照做，我的意思是，有个老生常谈的话题，像“你想别人怎么对你，你就怎么对别人”。但它管用。它确实管用。陈词滥调之所以成为陈词滥调是有原因的。让别人做你想让他们做的事情的最好方法，就是你自己去做。他们看到了，就会想，哦，好吧。
But if you tell them that they should do it, they're not going to do it. Yeah. It's like a total, that's like I can confirm according to psychology that it's like a very real effect. And also, if you do something for them, they're more likely to like you as well. And if you do something like and you're more likely to like them. Like it's this whole interaction of like reciprocity. Like I've had this feeling recently where I'm like, I've started to understand why cliches are cliches. And that one like treat people how you want to be treated is like one of my favorites.
但如果你告诉他们应该这么做，他们是不会去做的。是的。这是一个彻底的，我可以根据心理学证实，这是一个非常真实的效应。而且，如果你为他们做点什么，他们也更有可能喜欢你。如果你做了一些事，你也会更有可能喜欢他们。就像这是一种互惠的整个互动过程。我最近有这种感觉，我开始理解为什么陈词滥调之所以是陈词滥调了。而“你想别人怎么对你，你就怎么对别人”就是我最喜欢的之一。
I'm like, oh, God, that's so wise. Like they were they were so right on that one. Yeah. So I went to my for undergrad. I did business school and had a negotiations class. And I don't remember anything from any of my classes. I have no memory. But this one really stuck with.
我觉得，天哪，这太明智了。他们在这点上真是太对 了。是的。所以我上大学时，读的是商学院，上过一门谈判课。我不记得我上过的任何课程的任何内容。我没有任何记忆了。但这一条深深地印在了我脑海里。
me and they gave us this one talking point where when someone, where when you do something for someone and they say thank you, you tell them, oh, no problem at all. I know you'd do the same for me. And you're like reinforcing reciprocity. I was like, oh, we're sneaky. See, there you go guys. A little bit of manipulation. It can't go far enough. I have one final question for you. What is one piece of advice? This is a question we ask everybody. What is one piece of advice that you have for people in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we talked about today, nothing to do with ADHD, nothing to do with any of the themes we touched on. Just a piece of advice from you to them.
他们给了我们这样一个谈话要点：当有人，当你为别人做了什么，他们对你说谢谢时，你告诉他们，“哦，没关系，我知道你也会为我这么做的。”你是在强化互惠。当时我想，哦，我们真狡猾。看吧，各位。一点点小小的操纵。它能走得很远。我有一个最后的问题要问你。你有什么建议？这是我们问每个人的问题。你对20多岁的人有什么建议，这与我们今天讨论的内容无关，与 ADHD 无关，与我们涉及的任何主题都无关。只是你给他们的一条建议。
Based on my experience, I would say just experiment and have fun. I think that oftentimes we take everything a little bit too seriously and we get lost in things that we later on decide weren't even important to us to begin when. So what that looks like for me is really just doing some work, figuring out kind of what your values are. They might change over time. But just putting a little bit thought behind them and then just ensuring you're living semi accordingly to them and then just experimenting. Because sometimes you don't really know what you're going to like or if something's going to feel good for you unless you actually, unless you try it. And a lot of the times people get caught up too early picking a path. and especially, I know you said don't say ADHD, but especially for 80s who are super, who are like
根据我的经验，我会说：去尝试，去享受乐趣。我认为很多时候我们把一切都看得太严肃了，迷失在那些后来发现从一开始对我们根本不重要的事情中。所以对我来说，这意味着做一些工作，弄清楚你的价值观是什么。它们可能会随着时间而改变。但只要在它们背后投入一些思考，然后确保你的生活在某种程度上与它们保持一致，然后去尝试。因为有时你并不知道自己会喜欢什么，或者某事是否会让你感觉良好，除非你真的去尝试。很多时候，人们过早地陷入选择一条道路中。尤其是，我知道你说过不要提 ADHD，但特别是对于那些超级多才多艺的 ADHD 患者来说，他们有很多爱好，社会告诉我们需要选择一个职业，了解自己的目标，然后余生都这么做。如果你的脑子里有这种说法，那就真的很难，因为谁能在18岁时就知道自己想做什么呢？我认为这正在发生变化。我真的认为这是社会犯下的最大错误之一，那就是让人们在那么年轻的时候就做决定。我只是觉得有那么多的不快乐，有那么多人变得对错误的事情着迷，比如金钱、财富或地位，因为他们在18岁时选择的东西注定是他们余生必须做的事情。
multi-potentialites and they have lots of hobbies and we're told by society that you need to pick one career and know your purpose and just do it for the rest of your life. And if you have that narrative in your head, it is really difficult because who knows when they're 18 what they want to do? And I think that's really changing. I honestly think that's like one of the biggest mistakes that society has made is making people decide so young. I just feel like there's so much unhappiness and so many people who become like obsessed with the wrong things like money and like wealth or like status because like what they chose at 18 was meant to be the thing they had to do for the rest of their life.
所以，我喜欢这个建议，并且完全产生共鸣。好吧，我要非常感谢你能来。即使作为一个没有 ADHD 的人，我其实也非常喜欢其中的一些建议，对于一个独自工作、很容易分心的人来说，这些建议真的太有用了。人们在哪里可以找到你，在哪里可以找到 Shimmer？Shimmer 的网址是 shimmer.care，我在 Instagram 上是 adhd.christle，是的，直接访问我们的网站，那是了解我们所做事情的最简单方法。无论你还是你认识的人有 ADHD，我们都有成人 ADHD 计划，还有青少年 ADHD 计划。
So I love that advice and I totally resonate with it. Well, I want to say thank you so much for coming on. Even as someone who doesn't have ADHD, I actually loved some of those tips just for like genuine as someone who works by themselves and can get distracted very easily like they're just so helpful where can people find you and where can people find shimmer shimmer is at shimmer. care and i'm at instagram adhd.christle and yeah just head to our website that's the easiest way to learn about what we do whether you or someone you know has ADHD we have the ADHD for adults program and then we have the ADHD for teens program.
所以有各种各样的行为支持和社区支持。我们的目标其实就是让每个 ADHD 患者都能发挥他们的全部潜力，并且以适合他们自己的方式去实现。我觉得这太棒了。很高兴你能来作客。大家记得去关注克里斯以及她的所有作品。太棒了。如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们一个五星好评。
So all sorts of behavioral supports and community supports. The goal is really just for everyone with ADHD to reach their full potential and also reach it in their own way that works for them. Which I just think is amazing. Well, it was such a pleasure to have you on board. Remember guys to go and check Chris out and all of her work. It's fantastic. And if you enjoyed this episode, give us a five-star review.
把它分享给你认为可能需要听听它的朋友。并在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology Podcast。如果你想提供任何反馈，如果你对这一集或任何其他集有任何进一步的问题或想法，如果你想让我们详细阐述我们讨论过的任何内容，或者如果你只是想看看幕后花絮，我们非常欢迎你在那里与我们交流。但直到下次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
share it with a friend who you think might need to hear it. And follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to, you know, give any feedback. If you have any further questions or thoughts about this episode or any other episodes, if you want us to expand on anything we talked about, or if you just want to see behind the scenes, we'd love to have you over there. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难成长》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一副盔甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你可不是好惹的。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way. with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。就是在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索 TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定亲自采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。关于你自己的一点，我罩着你。《Look Back At It》播客。从1979年开始，
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. On the little bit of you, I got you. Back at it podcast. From 1979,
这对我是个很大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
并试着和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何挺过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。
and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
那是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 上收听《Look Back At It》，
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
或者在你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克特被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一支网络侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marincini.
我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。